excited excited to be here excited for
y'all to see me as I you know starts to
go into a new phase in my career will be
a big change probably in two years or so
I'll post up the video as the shift
happens it's gonna be a crazy since we
have post up the video of you I'm a game
show host now what that's how you play -
inside please that might be the only way
you great finger rock is kicking
[Music]
wait a minute oh space night it's really
fun but I like to just sit around and
talk [ __ ] playing space
of spades in my life I want to do I have
to monetize it because I have high
overheads in my life anyways I'll see
him it's not the wheel that deals don't
play that big joke around of all I'm
sure they still up in the slumming
wait what the hell at me I don't know
why it has been a spatial there's five
thousand poker souls and Pope is born
though still don't even talk to each
other so far almost us you know don't
even talk to each other poker so you
know what it's okay if you can't stand
it cause it ain't yo [ __ ] they don't
even talk to each other on poker so like
chips they don't even talk to each other
poker so oh you need of it Sadie's
netbook right here when you need
okay okay I thought it was a black dude
yeah my social surgery and look at this
look who's on look who came through I
you know how tough it is to get people
to do stuff that pays less than a
thousand dollars and I had a 95 percent
booking rate with this show
don't try to question that Matt might be
95 City but most of you say
I need space space like a sport man I do
it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
spades night it's Payne's night
[Music]
[Music]
fix all this imposter just blaze don't
sue me this is a great beat also who's
getting it what network wants this
Netflix Hulu lifetime the golf Network
what a space was on the golf Network you
could be groundbreaking take risks I see
you there at your desk sitting there
watching this with deadlines on the
other tabs just get the show man
[Music]